grave écart de langage ou traduction au
vitriol de l'exaspération que nourrit
dans les milieux politiques la situation
en Nouvelle-Calédonie un vif et grave
incident a opposé cet après-midi à
l'Assemblée nationale au cours des
questions au Gouvernement un député RPR
Didier Julia qui est le délégué national
du Mouvement au DomTom et le président
de l'Assemblée Louis Mermaz après une
suspension de séance le Premier ministre
Laurent Fabius a dit son indignation
Jean-Louis leer
si vous arriviez contre la Constitution
contre la démocratie à donner le pouvoir
à une petite minorité appuyé sur des
bandes armées vous aurez découvert le
national socialisme et cela nous ne
l'accepterons pas ce n'est pas possible
de laisser traîner des mots aussi sales
ce n'est pas possible retirer ces
expressions je
regrette on n'a pas le droit de
déshonorer les gens même avec des S je
vous demande de retirer ces mots
monsieur le Président on n'a pas le
droit de déshonorer la France même avec
des actes en Nouvelle-Calédonie monsieur
Julien vous me faites vraiment pitié je
m'excuse la séance est suspendue une
heure plus tard le bureau de l'Assemblée
n'ayant pas prononcé de sanction le
président stigmatise sans plus et
d'exprimer ici mes chers collègues une
très profonde
réprobation Monsieur le Premier
Ministre mesames et messieurs
le mot d'apar et le mot de nazisme pour
qualifier
l'attitude de la majorité et du
gouvernement est indigne est
indigne je permettra de vous dire
Monsieur s'agissant du nazisme et ses
conséquences sur la vie des hommes que
dans ma famille moi je sais ce que ça
veut
dire